Speaker 1: President Joe Biden was confronted
yesterday by Fox News reporter Peter Doocy about
the growing headache that these classified
documents are becoming for the Biden
administration. Oh, but, David, you'll never talk
about this. Say so many of you that email me. I've
talked about it all along. Oh, but, David, you'll
say that it shouldn't even be investigated. No. As
I've said all along, investigate everything,
investigate everything and come to whatever
conclusions the facts point to. The latest news
from the Associated Press. Biden team Finds more
Documents with Classified Markings. President
Joe Biden's legal team has discovered additional
documents containing classification markings in a
second location. This comes days after an attorney
for Biden's for president said Biden's lawyers
had discovered a small number of documents.
The person who spoke to the AP Wednesday said the
president's legal team found additional material,
classified material, at a second
location. They are talking about
a garage. Peter doocy confronts joe
biden yesterday about this. And here
is how that conversation went.
Speaker 2: Classified material.
Next year, corvette will be painting. Then he had
a chance to speak on all of this, God willing,
soon. But as I said earlier this week, people and
by the way, my Corvettes in the lock garage. Okay,
So it's not like you're sitting on the street
rooting for us. Yes. As well as my Corvette.
But as I said earlier this week, people know I
take classified documents and classified material
seriously. I also said we're cooperating fully and
completely with the Justice Department's review.
As part of that process, my lawyers reviewed
other places where documents in my of from
my time as vice president were stored.
And they finished the review last night.
They discovered a small number of documents
of classified markings in storage areas and
file cabinets in my home and my
and my my, my personal library.
This was done in the case of the Biden plans, and
this was done in the case of the Biden Pen Center.
The Department of Justice was immediately as
was done. Department of Justice was immediately.
Speaker 1: So at the reading of this statement
is not going particularly well for Joe Biden.
Jason Kander had a very good tweet about
the contrast between the Biden and the Trump
classified documents situation. Now, those of you
who really know me know that I could not care less
about whether there is a D, R and R next to Joe
Biden or Trump's name when it comes to how these
situations should be handled, investigate all of
them. And I think what will become very clear as
a piece of my microphone just exploded is that
the circumstances are, of course, so dramatically
different. And Jason Sanders tweet was, quote,
classified documents, a shopping analogy. As Biden
walked out, the buzzer went off and he realized he
mistakenly failed to pay for an item in his cart.
He went back in and returned it. Trump stuffed
items in his pockets when the buzzer sounded,
he ran to his car and peeled out. I have
said it all week and I will say it again
Investigate everyone. This doesn't exonerate
Donald Trump any more than an accused murderer
would be exonerated because of someone else
accused of murder somewhere else in a completely
unrelated case. These are two completely separate
things. The facts are different. The reaction
was different. The circumstances are different.
And it's so evident that everything about these
two situations is so, so different. So Fox is
getting a lot of mileage from this. Donald Trump,
I'm sure, is thrilled about the fact that this
is going on. But these are two very different
situations. They should both be investigated and
let's let the cards fall where they may. See,
I'm not saying oh, but do let the cards fall where
they may. And Peter Doocy is going to get his
licks, there is no doubt about it. But it does
not do a damn thing to exonerate Donald Trump